the Grand Theft Auto 6 trailer just
dropped last evening and it was wild and
I'm not just talking about the whole lot
of ass we saw in the footage itself so
let's talk about the trailer what you
might have missed the leak itself and
Rockstar's unprecedented response to all
of
[Music]
this after 10 years four releases a
little bit of cowboy action in between
and absolutely zero single player DLC
see we finally have a new trailer for
the next Grand Theft Auto and boy was it
something we got twerking mudding Gators
and what I can only assume is a ton of
weird characters it legitimately looks
like GTA 5 on steroids which makes sense
since the game takes place in Vice City
Rockstar's version of Miami and the
surrounding areas in Florida like the
keys and Everglades from what we know so
far you play as Lucia a lady that looks
very similar to that leak we saw in 2022
more on that later but is this the only
character that we play as is the lover
we see in the trailer also playable is
this just one character trailer of many
to come only time will tell on that one
now the trailer starts with our
protagonist in prison Garb so either the
game begins in jail or you end up there
hopefully the latter and the rest of the
trailer is just a bunch of other Florida
Shenanigans and a lot of social media
content Grand Theft Auto has always done
its best to be as relevant as possible
and although we don't know the exact
year that this game takes place it's
safe to assume from the footage that
we've seen that it's pretty current so
my question is how much is social media
going to play a role in the game itself
will it be like previous titles where
it's just a smattering of flavor to the
world or will it be a legit mechanic one
thing I'm pretty confident about is the
return of more robbery and Heist
gameplay although GTA has always been a
franchise about well theft it has been
elevated ever since the release of five
and this trend continued with Red Dead
Redemption 2 my best bet is that Heist
have become the safe motif for Rockstar
moving forward and that this title is
going to include a lot of that among
what I can only assume is a bunch of
other insane now if you somehow
haven't seen this record-breaking
trailer yet go have a look break it down
frame by frame Lord knows you got the
time since this puppy ain't coming out
until
[Music]
what oh my God according to the press
release GTA 6 will only be released on
the PS5 Xbox series X there was a large
conversation whether or not the next GTA
title was going to start as a console
exclusive like the past titles and I
guess this settles it so if you don't
have one yet you have at least 12 1/2
months to figure that out but with all
of that squared away we need to talk
about the elephant in the room which is
how why and when this trailer was
released it did not go as planned in
November Rockstar told us that they
would be releasing a trailer in early
December that date ended up being today
the 5th but but millions of people had
already seen it yesterday this is
because less than 24 hours before
schedule the fulling thing was leaked to
Twitter by some random who slapped their
crypto Watermark across the screen and
this is hardly the first time GTA 6
faced leakage issues as many know back
in 2022 over 20 minutes of pre-alpha
footage was leaked and it eventually led
to the arrest of a 17-year-old in the UK
who is currently awaiting judgment after
being deemed unfit to stand trial but
this wasn't even the first time that GTA
6 was leaked this week just two days ago
fragments of what looked like a new GTA
allegedly leaked a Tik Tok via the son
of an employee at Rockstar but this most
recent leak was the straw that broke the
camels back because minutes after it was
posted Rockstar dropped the whole thing
themselves ahead of schedule saying
quote our trailer has leaked so please
watch the real thing on YouTube in my
opinion this was the right call yes it
sucks that they were so close to the
actual schedule but it was clearly just
going to keep happening and people were
going to find a way to circulate the
leak so I will will say it does all seem
like the most Rockstar possible thing to
happen leaked in 2022 by a kid deemed
unfit to stand trial then leaked again
by another kid who turns out to be the
son of an employee only to be leaked a
third time by a person trying to shill
their crypto it's almost poetic it's
unknown what other legal action Rockstar
is going to take or if they'll just wash
their hands of the whole thing given
that they're about to make like a
bajillion dollars all that really
matters is that we have a new Grand
Theft Auto coming out sometime in 202
five which means we are one step closer
to getting a new Red Dead
Redemption you think blp kosher is going
to be in the game you don't know blp
kosher h no he's a rapper from uh Brower
County in Florida and uh I was really
disappointed that they didn't use him
for the uh the
trailer was the song they used Tom Petty
I
think it was an interesting choice